hey good news you know how you see
movies these days and you just think to
yourself they just don't make them like
they used to you know like they just
don't make classics like the Dark
Crystal well they actually do legend of
the guardians the owls of ga'hoole that
is a mouthful all right so I first saw
the trailer to the legends of the
guardians and it says Zack Snyder
directed it and I thought oh hey that's
awesome I like his other movies you know
Watchmen 300 Dawn of the Dead great but
this movie is told through owls
I just don't know so the story goes
Sauron is this young wide-eyed owl who
knows the story of the legends of the
Guardians of Ga'Hoole and he is
convinced they're real and guess what
well I'm not going to tell you if
they're real or not it being in a title
and all and from there he gets kidnapped
put into slavery and then our epic goes
on with owls so I am NOT gonna lie I
actually really enjoyed this movie I
mean I thought the movie was really well
done it had good characters good
dialogue with the characters an evil
villain it even has some sibling rivalry
in it I mean honestly I think this movie
might be that classic movie that this
generation grows up on like Dark Crystal
and labyrinth was for us or should be
anyway have you seen the that's out
these days and the battles in this movie
were straight-up like Zack Snyder
badassery the battles in this movie were
badass with owls
I mean how horrible is that when fights
with owls are better than most of this
that we've seen this year I mean
one of my real regrets in this movie is
the movies about an hour and a half long
I think and honestly I probably could
have watched it for about three hours a
three hour version of the legends of the
guardian of Ga'Hoole that would push it
right over to epic I hope it was like a
special edition DVD or blu-ray that
comes out when this movie comes out so
maybe we'll get our three-hour version
that way I don't know maybe at least two
hours I mean it was fun it was easy to
watch it was cool it reminded me of the
good old days of 80s epic movies but it
was a little short and partisan I wish
some of the characters they'd elaborate
on a little more for some weird reason
man I walked out of this movie with a
big smile on my face I mean I've already
seen some critics just nitpick the
out of this movie and they're always
like yeah it's not - tor - fools that is
my official impersonation of a douchebag
I mean honestly man sometimes just relax
and in
enjoy the movie unleash your inner child
and it's a fantasy movie and the
cool one at that it's a series of books
and the end of this movie sets up for a
sequel and I really hope the sequel gets
made Scott Pilgrim has taught me that
awesome does not mean success I swear to
God if this movie becomes like the Scott
Pilgrim scenario I am going to Tibet and
I'm becoming a monk I can't see good
get on all the time I mean
does the movie look great yes good
cinematography absolutely is that all
there is to the movie no absolutely not
I don't think so I enjoyed the out
of this movie to a surprising degree
even had that song that creepy song
that's at the end of the mist it's also
in the Terminator 3 trailer anything
with that creepy ass some automatically
goes up a couple notches in my book I
was gonna call this movie the legends of
the guardians of gay whole' if it sucked
but it didn't so for my money legend of
the guardians the owls of ga'hoole is
awesome tacular so go check it out you
will have a good time if you have kids
take your kids they're gonna love it I'm
gonna watch the movie again in a river
of a DD cartoons and raise your
kids on something right like this is
your duty as a parent and that's my PSA
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]